[Music]
former facebook data scientist frances
haugen recently testified before a
senate subcommittee she shared many
internal company secrets revealing that
facebook knowingly engages in unethical
practices these revelations have sent
shock waves throughout the country when
asked about facebook's secretive nature
haugen said that it results in more
division more harm more lies more
threats and more combat and this shocked
a lot of americans yet for even more of
us the reaction was
[Music]
doy doy doy
who didn't know that freakin door toy
door
for you're saying something we already
knew
[Music]
but
francis haugen wasn't done she also said
facebook when confronted with a conflict
of issue between its profits and the
common good consistently chose to
prioritize its profits again some people
were shocked to find that out but
some of us were all like
[Music]
dipping door dipping door door door
dipping
door
door door that's a dump for you
your mama and your bullets
she went on to drop even more bombs like
saying
in some cases this dangerous online talk
has led to actual violence that harms
and even kills people
oh
whoa that's heavy
yeah it is
wow
yeah
wow
[Music]
don't
[Music]
[Applause]
do it
[Music]
you